David who were you in high school if  we're in 10th Grade who were you in high  school I was a nerdy little kid uh if  you asked my high school class who would  be the most successful person in class  most people wouldn't know I was in the  class I was a large public high school 1  500 people in my class in your class my  class so it was big we had one guidance  counselor for 1 500 people  um it was I would say uh you know big  public high school Melting Pot public  high school but I was I skipped a year  of junior high school so I was only you  know 16 when I graduated high school I  was only 14 when I entered it so I was  you know probably young my boys probably  hadn't changed very much and you know I  was not a great athlete I wasn't a great  scholar I wasn't a great anything so the  same was true in law school and and in  college I wasn't great at anything I got  lucky later in life